[Music]
what's going on guys we are back in
studio back from comic-con I've got the
sunburn to prove it and today we're
breaking down all the news or lack
thereof that came out of Comic Con and
we've got an awesome panel to talk about
it with first he is a comic book writer
he's written for DC and Marvel currently
Batwoman mark and Draco woman oh and he
is also a great friend of the show he is
the head badass at badass digest Devin
Faraci hello all right so let's talk
about the news that came out this year
last year was huge you had the
announcement of Batman vs. Superman with
that iconic logo coming up they
announced Avengers 2 age of Ultron
comparatively this year was it a
disappointment Devin I know you spent a
lot of time in volley yeah I live in
hole H at Comic Con it was it was kind
of a letdown but only because I think
that we've been so spoiled by the past
couple of years especially by Marvel
Marvel has done such an incredible job
year after year of not just making their
panel and event you know having Tom
Hiddleston come out as Loki was like
what an enormous event this year it was
really Loki they wanted an ounce Loki
that was not even on purpose thank you
even the stuff with Warner Brothers we
kind of were hoping we're gonna find out
the Justice League we're gonna find out
all this kind of stuff having the cash
that they do have come out and then just
stand there staring at the fans it was
the weirdest thing ever
yeah and Affleck Henry Cavill and gal
gadot come out and just stare out of
college it really was like this parading
show ponies and I'm wondering if that
was part of Ben Affleck's contract
because he was certainly brave to go
into a room of thousands of people that
said that was the worst thing ever since
the Black Plague but that's why I wanted
him to come out pick up the mic put on
his Batman voice and be like how do you
like me now nerds well I gotta say I was
I even though the footage was really
really short I thought that Batman
Superman footage was pretty amazing it
made me it made me one don't come back
next year and see the extent of the
longer footage before they release it in
two years and I was really really
impressed Devin you were in a Hall H win
that play talk to me about the reaction
of the energy in the room it was
enormous I mean people really exploded I
mean to be able to see any footage at
all was exciting this particular bit of
footage is really well done for me the
DC stuff was mixed because that footage
was great
yeah but then the Wonder Woman costume I
found to be extraordinarily lacking Oh
snow warrior princess you mean it's just
I just it's like they went with the very
famous brown version of Wonder Woman I
don't really understand why Zack Snyder
he doesn't like multiple colors once
again it's two years out it's a teaser
image and I'm sure since we're gonna
have 76 different action figures from
every character in this movie I'm sure
she's gonna have 12 or 13 different
costumes so the reaction of Hall H to
the Batman Superman footage was colossal
what was the reaction comparatively to
The Avengers 2 age of Ultron footage it
was enormous as well I mean the thing
about the Avengers footage is that
Marvel totally understands their
audience and so it opens with this party
scene of all these characters
interacting and having fun what we love
about these character actors and then
everything goes terribly wrong and then
the rest of the footage just sells you
the idea the Avengers are totally
outclassed so I think that the reaction
was enormous I think Marvel kind of
actually blew it by not showing it twice
the whole H loves to see this footage
twice they show Batman vs Superman twice
and I don't know when these studios are
gonna realize that they should release
it on the internet instantly after thank
you keep that snowball effect ago I
disagree I disagree totally I to me
here's the thing is that I've been
coming to comic-con for a long time I've
been on college for a long time yes part
of the appeal and the whole point of
going there is to see things that are
exclusive and special to this event if
it's all on the internet immediately why
even go but if you're a movie studio if
you're conglomerate like a Disney or a
Warner Brothers do you want to serve the
6,000 people in Hall H or the 600
million people that are instantly gonna
watch it when they hear what it was in
it it doesn't I get it but it seems like
diminishing returns I'm just waiting for
the huge backlash because fans are
fickle and they like everything until
they don't yeah no I get serving the
fans but but when is when is San Diego
been about the fans in the past 10 years
it's become a trade show that fans are
allowed to go to um how do we think
ant-man is shaping up well I don't
Peyton Reed I know I've known for years
and I think Peyton's a really great
director I'm not envious of his
situation you know after coming into
Batwoman after a beloved creative team
left I definitely relate to going into
that job but I think Peyton's gonna be
great Peyton is a really great director
he's got a real nice mix he's got he's
the best of the Marvel style he balances
the humor with the serious really really
well and he's a real hardcore nerd he
also has a really great comedy
background people don't realize oh yeah
they see mr. Shue
directed most of that stuff so I mean
like he has the the real cred I'll he
gets the gallon think he gets the the
props from the fans because they just
look and they see the break-up and they
say yes man on his resume but he has the
the depth all right sort to your throat
tell me who won Marvel or DC I work for
him do you see Marvel all right this was
this was preordained I can see where
this was gonna go in advance you know
what I'll say legendary whoo
legendary really knocked it out the park
with some of their stuff this yeah I
think announcing not just Godzilla - but
then announcing what monsters are gonna
be in Godzilla - that's the movie I want
right yeah you're gonna have your moth
where you gonna have your Rodin that was
one of the biggest complaints from me
about this current Godzilla movie I love
the tone but I want it like you know one
or two more boss battles but that I
think the part of the issue was they
needed to negotiate the rights with Toho
that's kind of a smart move on behalf of
Toho considering how bad the Matthew
Broderick Godzilla was oh yeah yeah it's
like okay let's see how you do with this
time around and we'll give you the
monsters piecemeal yeah I really the
movie was sort of like mixed from from a
fan point of view but Toho loved the new
bed Zilla King Kong Skull Island huge do
you think we're gonna see a King Kong
vs. Godzilla is that the setup or oh I
can't imagine that we're not going to if
they're all under the same roof there's
an interesting that's an interesting
nerd issue about this yeah is that the
new Godzilla is 10 times larger than any
previous cause yes so King Kong is
basically gonna be just punching him in
the balls
King Kong zoo me like a little Gibbon on
his shoulder episode I think you know
what I mean well you've got if you've
got written in there with all the
radiation you've got there doing tests
nuclear tests by Skull Island and Kahn
gets mutated hmm so let's stop big
losers for me hands down
Fox to have a Fantastic Four movie in
production right now yeah and to not
even have a logo or a video message this
was the opportunity to say to the fans
hey we're actually doing something
interesting here and they didn't take it
I thought the Star Wars was the biggest
loser I thought for a movie that's
coming out next Christmas and I know
Disney will save it for their
promotional things but just have the
logo and the beginning of the John
Williams theme and maybe just cuts of
just Stills all the different care you
know I was hoping for star
I was hoping for dr. strange come on
Disney give us a little thing about Star
Wars is sort of sad is that they're
being so secretive that fans just even
something as simple as the name of the
movie would have sent shockwaves oh we
have our Star Wars name generator' I
want each of you to give it one spin
okay and we will determine what the new
mark if you would give it we're gonna
give it two spins Gungans Devon the
Gungans Senate so it's gonna be a bunch
of Jar Jar Binks is so there's so we're
just releasing Phantom Menace Wow
that's if you if you thought we could
not get worse than the prequels get
ready for Gungan Senate all right let's
just put it on the table what was the
best thing that you saw at comic-con oh
the Mad Max footage because I had zero
expectations for that being good and I
now can't wait to see that I mean it
came out of nowhere
it blew the hall up it was the most
amazing thing that we saw and everybody
we ever they were surprised and then
they were just absolutely blown away by
the beautiful practical effects the
incredible action it was just
unbelievable what did you think about
comic-con what did you wish there was
more of what were you excited to hear
about leave us a comment below we want
to know what you thought I gotta thank
my panel mark and Draco Devin Faraci
thanks so much fellas you rule and by
the way you guys rule you are so awesome
at comic-con it was so great meeting all
the screen junkies fans we're giving you
another bonus episode tomorrow more
crazy footage more fun cosplay is it too
much never
check us out tomorrow more awesome Comic
Con coverage thanks so much for watching
I'm Howard I'll take hit me up on
Twitter bye bye
[Music]